(rock music)
- It's now time for
tonight's hashtag wars.
(cheering)
(suspenseful music)
(ding)
Kate.
- Four cannibals and a funeral.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(ding)
- He's just not that into cunnilingus.
- Points, Jim.
- Kidney failure to launch.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(ding)
Kate.
- When Harry killed Sally.
- Yes, points, Jim.
(ding)
- How to lose a pregnancy in 10 days.
(all laughing)
(audience cheering)
- [Chris] Points.
(ding)
Arden.
- Never been fist.
(audience laughing)
- [Chris] Points
(ding)
- Kate Walsh.
- Yay, 40 year old anal virgin.
(all laughing)
(suspenseful music)
(ding)
- [Chris] Doug Benson.
- Fish farts.
(laughing)
Both spelled with a P-H.
- [Chris] Yes, points, points, points.
(ding)
Greg Behrendt.
- (Bleep) raisin.
(laughing)
(audience clapping)
- [Chris] That image, yes.
- I like raisins.
- [Chris] Points, Doug.
(ding)
- Banana spliff.
- Yes, points, Esther.
(ding)
- Cherry Springer.
- [Chris] Cherry Springer,
yes, points, well done.
(ding)
Doug Benson.
- Chocolate chip cookie Doug.
- Yes, points.
(ding)
The ice cream that's so
high, it eats itself.
(audience laughing)
Esther.
- Mint chocolate Cheney.
- [Chris] Yes, points, yeah points.
(ding)
Greg Behrendt.
- I wanna go with corn nuts,
Hang on, caveat.
It's not corn nut the corn nut,
it's the nuts of the band Korn.
(laughing)
A really awful ice cream.
- Yeah, points.
(dings)
Doug.
- People don't know this, but chubby hubby
was originally called fat (bleep)er.
(laughing)
(suspenseful music)
(ding)
- Guy Branum.
- Rear-Enders game.
- Yes, points.
(ding)
And on that note, (bleep)
you Orson Scott Card.
(all laughing)
Ally Wong.
- Indiana Jones and the temple of poon.
- Yes, points.
(ding)
Ron.
- Dr. Who's that in my butt?
(all laughing)
(audience clapping)
- Why, is it bigger on the inside?
Points for Ron Funches.
(ding)
Guy Branum.
- Triple X-Men, first ass.
- Yes, points, wow.
Nice, next, Ron.
(ding)
- Fahrenheit 69.
- Yes, points, Guy.
(ding)
- My dick, the gathering.
(all laughing)
It stars Zac Efron.
- [Chris] It stars Zac
Efron, points for that.
Yes, points, Ron Funches.
(ding)
- Lord of the (bleep) ring.
- Yes, points, Ali.
(ding)
- Bill Nye the Science Guy on guy.
(laughing)
- On this guy?
- On Guy Branum.
- [Chris] Points, points, points.
(ding)
Ron Funches.
- Men in Black men in black men.
(all laughing)
(audience clapping)
- These are so metta.
- [Chris] Points to Ron Funches.
(ding)
Guy.
- Doctor really strange love.
- [Chris] Yes, points, it got a snort,
you get 100 points.
(ding)
Ron.
- Star Wars, but with (bleep)ing.
(all laugh)
(suspenseful music)
(ding)
- [Chris] Yes, Jen.
- Pharrell Williamsburg.
- Nice, good one, points.
(ding)
Morgan.
- Amy man boobs.
- Points.
(ding)
Paul F. Tompkins.
- Sons and Roses, the Mumford and Sons
and Guns N' Roses tribute mash-up band.
(audience cheering)
- I say, welcome to the jungle.
(ding)
Jen.
- Foster the people's choice awards.
- [Chris] Yes points.
(ding)
Morgan, hit it.
Morgan, sorry, Paul.
- Adele Dazeem.
(laughing)
(ding)
- Points, Morgan.
- Tegan and Sarah Palin.
- Yes, points.
(audience clapping)
(ding)
- Lana Del Rachel Ray.
- [Chris] Yes, excellent, points.
Paul F.
- Kecha, which is like Kesha,
but with a cent sign instead.
(laughing)
(buzzer)
(rock music)